so weird would you say that your
worldview has been updated in the last
six months oh I mean I think that's like
I think that's always a hard question I
think I can give you a couple profound
ones but I want you to go first but like
I mean I think the biggest thing to me
has been like and maybe I'm still coming
to realize exactly like understand what
it means but like I think I think the
lens and the perspective that I'm seeing
things from is slowly evolving yeah like
I'm seeing sort of the mecca nations of
society and rather than as some big
abstract machine like it's just people
doing another thing and following
patterns of incentives and doing what
makes them happy for better or worse
following what they think makes them
happy even if it doesn't and I guess
I've built a more profound understanding
of how people who are collectively
looking down at their feet and going
this is what's rational can collectively
be vastly irrational and do terrible
things like the global warming mess we
find ourselves in
but it's all just a chain of people
behaving individual irrationally yeah
that's a good one the individual ways of
following some of society's programming
that have caused us to find ourselves in
so much of the error situations that
we're in now you're right we're
following a scent of structures that are
that are misaligned with our collective
interest they're misaligned they're
misaligned with our interconnectedness
with nature and this is probably one of
the ones that I think is most salient
for me is that our disconnection from
nature is a is directly mirrored in the
ailments that our civilization has so
the more that a civilization disconnects
from source from the planet that gives
them nourishment the system that
sustains them the more errors that you
see in the society it's extremely
evident you listed one the way we're
affecting our ecosystems like people
people who don't see the big picture
fail to understand deeply the
implications of what they're doing yeah
yeah and I mean so much of that like one
of the big ideas in business computer
science like is abstraction like I love
abstraction we just did an episode on
abstraction yesterday on abstraction and
creativity yeah
with with Jeremy Nixon who's actually a
machine learning researcher at Google
brain yeah it was a great episode yeah
and he is on fire about abstraction
temporal abstraction just like normal
abstraction transfer learning language
creativity we talked about so much good
stuff in that section
I think abstraction in particular though
can be very it can be very good but very
dangerous like if you I mean I think the
computer science example is like you are
writing really high level code that is
very abstracted from what a processor is
doing and then it breaks in some
incredibly subtle way and you're like
what the heck why doesn't this work and
you have to maybe dig through layers and
layers of stuff that you totally arcane
you don't understand what it means to
realize like it's some work of the
architecture that you're using where if
you start out with that understanding
you can go oh this is not obviously not
a good thing but I think the same is
true like a ecology is a handy example
where
what really is good or bad to the planet
is not something you necessarily want to
connect to like oh yeah I went shopping
and I bought out-of-season fruit like
that's that's not a connection that just
pops into people's brains unless they
really understand like the logistic
system that goes into that yeah the
reason why app the abstraction of
understanding the nature that sustains
you is so important is because that is
the source of all life and the lack of
gratitude that we have to the source of
all life to every breath that we take
it's every sip of water it's every
shower to every piece of food to the
trees and the insects of the animals and
the ecosystems around us to the ocean
that's right next to still all these
things that have birthed us in here to
this driving life force is the greatest
disconnection that we've ever made in
our lives it's a fall from grace and
that's why seven plus billion people are
on the playground just playing in the
amusement park and not consciously
connecting to nature to what sustains
them that's been one of the most
profound worldview updates that I've had
thanks to the Colombian elder mom Andrew
John thank you thank you to that
indigenous wisdom so so important that
indigenous wisdom and the other really
important worldview update I had was
with with was with reading Junior's book
interdependent capitalism and I'll give
you a copy of this on the way out one of
the best books I've ever read in my life
and it does an incredible synthesis at
all the way back from the the inclusive
fitness that kin tribes have yeah and
how our family values just did not scale
with time and so we find ourselves in
this massive global village of self
dealing stories used to be told in the
tribe because I would tell you a story
to help your fitness it was both in our
best interest for me to tell you a true
story that helped your fitness now in
today's culture people tell each other
stories to sell them [ __ ] that they
don't need and so you have you have you
have you have politicians that are not
aligned you have doctors physicians that
are not aligned you have teachers that
are not aligned all our aligning systems
are off we're obsessed with our nuclear
families we're obsessed with our kids
were obsessed with our dogs and our cats
and we don't know our neighbors and we
don't find it to be like we need
inclusive steak holding Silicon Valley
did something right which was that they
gave shares to the employees that we're
building the company's great but that's
only one step in the right direction the
next step is all of the customers that
literally call the uber on the phone
should also get very small percentages
of ownership into the company they're
the ones that are driving the worth of
that company and then uber has found
itself headquartered in downtown San
Francisco for how many years almost a
decade or something and it's going to be
approaching a decade soon and how much
has ober finds themselves in an
inclusive steak holding fashion with San
Francisco not really at all
uber needs to be an inclusive
stakeholder entity within the city of
San Francisco they need to give back
they need San Francisco to be a
shareholder of uber these are some of
the mechanisms of these of this
Universal basic asset movement of this
inclusive stake holding movement this
global village of inclusive fitness
movement that we need to move towards
and they recommend a lot of really good
solutions to the problem like some
things like blockchain technology enable
us to have a decentralized digital
ledger that shows how a teacher or a
physician has an inclusive stake in
their pupil and that the psychologic the
psychology of terms like compersion like
that compersion means i feel joy when
you feel joy vicariously through you we
need new words we need neologisms for
these things we need music that is not
about money and women and materialistic
possessions and drugs but we need music
that is about interconnectedness so
these two things together interdependent
capitalism along with the indigenous
wisdom has been like one of the most
profound worldview updates for me and
it's added and added into my synthesis a
lot I really like I see an idea in there
like making the city a shareholder I
think I think that speaks deeply to like
the incentive structures of capitalism
like there's this idea that I've never
been totally comfortable with in like
how publicly traded companies operate if
you're a publicly traded company and
somebody on sharing you what obligation
exists to make money
like why that should be the exclusive
obligation to a shareholder like that I
feel like there's so much that in itself
is a corrupted first principle money
it's to make money that's a corrupted
first principle the first principle
needs to be to provide value to others
value yeah and not materialistic
deceptive value but value of maximizing
prosperity and our interconnectedness
with nature I mean look at all the
people who go in and like leveraged
buyout some company that's having
trouble and just completely destroy it
all of the value that it built up in
order to make a quick buck themselves
let's go through a practice Nick yeah
okay so when we breathe
when we do that what are we breathing
being oxygen nitrogen what what are we
sustained what are we sustained by I
mean the oxygen what ourselves what
produces what produces the air that's
plants mostly phytoplankton yeah plants
too yeah and yeah the the massive
ecosystem of the water cycle and the
cycle of air these cycles directly give
us the source of life directly not
indirectly but directly give us the
source of life eating a plant directly
gives us a source of life so how how
disconnected do you think we are from
that I mean in the last hundred years it
has grown at an extraordinary pace like
what else has grown at an extraordinary
pace all right think all of the issues
have grown at an extraordinary pace too
and when we do things like take people
out of poverty we need to really look at
things from a first principles
perspective because doing things like
tying people into monetary systems for
especially for people that are like
indigenously tie to land into the earth
they don't want money they don't want to
be part of the global economy but we
insist for them to be a part of the
global economy no no no you need
electricity you need internet you need
computers you need money you need bank
accounts you need this
we've been forcing that onto people
around the world instead of
query how they actually exist how do you
exist and connect to spirit learning
from people who are who live different
lives we're so far up in our own asses
here there was a person that we're gonna
have on the show soon that made that
they took and they scraped by city
people's Twitter profiles and made word
clouds of the of what were the most
common things in Silicon Valley it's
like product design Google Facebook blah
blah in other places in the United
States its father wife child family
loved God really like values said it's a
different life
and if you look at a word cloud of
indigenous people it's like spirit
nature source lungs of things that are
part of nature yeah trees plants animals
yeah
fruits yep food water yeah yeah so we
are you can take a word cloud of a area
to capture the zeitgeist of there's
connection to spirit I've been obsessing
with this stuff weird so disconnected
it's evident in our mental disorders
it's evident in the way that our social
fabric is not inclusive yeah there are
promising technologies that were made
like the internet they were supposed to
do the absolute thing that they promised
to do actually do the interconnectedness
at the most pinnacle level and social
media needs the upgrade to do to do to
do exactly what it was promised to do
right now it's so far deviated from that
we've given the space Nick this last
hundred years that you've mentioned yeah
the further that more and more of
civilization has disconnected from
nature the more there's been space for
evil to come into that void so evil is
filling the void of disconnection from
nature and that evil are things like
deception manipulation disconnection so
when someone that has a self-dealing
interest is trying to sell memes of
consumerism and people are disconnected
from nature that evil is able to succumb
and fill that spirit the body soul the
vehicle the vessel
I see what you're saying I wouldn't I
mean I think the disconnection I would
think about a lot in terms of like
in-group out-group so why why do people
behave the way they do so I think
there's a lot of people who really don't
want to hurt anybody
like who I would call like fundamentally
good they care about the people around
them they don't want to intentionally
hurt anybody but I think there's a lot
of apathy that's arisen from seeing an
increasingly wide out group who they're
hearing scary things about and social
media has absolutely fed that I don't
want I wouldn't call that like any sort
of intentional evil but it is a
terrifying consequence of disconnection
from each other
like how many people did somebody in the
1880s 1890's talk to on an average day
in person physically talk to him how
many people do you and I talk to
I think there is a big disparity
and I think that disconnection from each
other has done a lot about her
and disconnection from what sustains us
the thing that provided you and I and
all of us with a life we are
disconnected from provides we're
disconnected from the provider providers
and the deeper that disconnect has
become the more errors we found in
civilization the less of a disconnect
there is when more and more people
become consciously connected to nature
what sustains them and through simple
mechanisms like being grateful for that
even the breath being grateful for the
water that sustains you being grateful
for the food we were given the most
beautiful thing in the world which is
life we were given life and we've
disconnected ourselves so so far away
from the source of life so far away and
that is what all these malevolence is
why they have occurred so I think that
that unifying theory of what is going on
around us is become one of the most
important for me to embed into the
conversations that I have with these
tech science leaders that we have on the
program and it's been so fascinating
watching watching the reactions it's
been so fascinating the little tiny
nudges that we can make to help each
other connect more consciously to nature
the more we will see the problems of
society fade away over time the
hungriest of those that are in power
still clinging to megalomania is
clinging to corruption clinging to
deception will be eradicated with more
people consciously connecting they will
literally see it as an evil thing that
they do not want to partake in anymore
but right now it's still propagating the
meme of I get a lambo I get a Rolex I
get a house I get the things material
material women
drugs money it's just ticking ticking
all over the Instagram feeds that is the
Matt that is the vast majority of
content is not conscious enlightened
content and so the memes are propagating
at rapid speeds and causing further
disconnection the the level of global
chaotic chaos that's occurring right now
collective chaos unprecedented the
ecosystems are screaming at us we don't
even realize that when we do something
like pollute that it effects everything
else this is not a single I consume a
piece of plastic put it in the garbage
and it's gone forever
that gets buried in the landfill that
gets into the landfill and the
ecosystems of our planet
there's only a few orders of magnitude
our universe will permit us to grow
so
when we when we when we take something
like the civilization growing by orders
of magnitude it is one thing to have a
spiritually connected civilization to it
the rock that nourishes it and then go
alright let's see what we can make to
explore the cosmos and have a hundred
billion people instead of ten billion
people living here it's a completely
other thing to be have seven plus
billion people completely disconnected
from nature and then have other
megalomaniacs that are playing with the
toys of gods trying to escape from the
rock and go into the cosmos because this
is a story that is cyclical it's
happened before
those with power play with the toys of
God disconnect from nature civilization
collapses those with power play with the
toys of God megalomaniacs nature comes
out true civilization collapses it's a
cycle it's been happening it's gonna
happen again if we don't consciously
connect do you think do you think a
civilization who is deeply connected to
their planet would rise up to explore
the cosmos yes absolutely
what is their what is their motivation
exploration also to be with other
celestial bodies physically it's
exciting it's exciting it's if for
example if if everyone on the planet was
like the Ocoee tribe but the one in
Colombia twenty thousand of them in the
santa maria de marta Andean the Andes
the northern part of the Andes okay if
everyone on the planet was like them
then I agree with you that there would
be like to create a stewardship and
passion for for nature for where we come
from
and so it'd be like hmm shall we really
figure out how to leave this rock right
that's the question so younger brother
this is the narrative they have older
brother is connected to nature connected
to spirit younger brother is
disconnected from nature and spirit
younger brother is the one that does all
of the creative technology all that
stuff if younger brother was more aware
of nature and spirit it would be more
consciously making technology and
creativity but right now it's doing this
and that and this and that and this and
that that it's overwhelming our
civilization with disconnection from
nature and it's caused the self-dealing
non-inclusive steak holding it's caused
all of those issues so by by getting
younger brother more connected to to
nature and spirit we can have a younger
brother that can still do things like
make cool cosmic voyages okay
that's fair I was thinking was something
about like it it's easy if you're really
in harmony to be content
if you're content it's hard to summon
motivation to change I think you do need
a little bit of a balance there I think
that younger brother older brother
captures that yes he in the yin and yang
this has been for a long long time these
this all but all part of one all part of
source all part of what has birthed us
into the world the man and woman again
the younger brother older brother
dynamic the good and evil when again
when our spirit is not connected to
nature we leave a void within us for
deception for evil to come in
we don't even consciously realize the
programming that we live in in culture
we have to step back step into spirit oh
I'm a divine being that was given life
on this rock and I am so blessed for it
oh drinking water eating food I'm so
blessed for the nourishment doing that
cyclically being by the ocean being by
the woods feeling trees feeling water
feeling animals feeling those things at
the deepest most visceral ways solves
all of the issues in civilization it's a
first order first principle error that
we're at everything else is a band-aid
everything else is a second order third
order solution that is causing more
issues it's a hard solution to implement
it's only as hard as our reap reap a
turning our behaviors to go
unconsciously connect to nature and then
to help share that meme of how beautiful
the experiences are with others and have
others also respect the sacred lands of
our planet the sacred interconnectedness
of everything this has been the
worldview update on yeah what do you
think about it you've been giving me
some but what do you think about yeah I
mean I I don't think I've really been
hiding like I think I think I've seen a
lot of I think the balanced narrative
has something to it like I think there's
a lot of ways to encapsulate that yeah
like you could think of it as I really
don't like the good evil because I don't
think either of them is bad I think the
access of them is both bad mm-hmm
like I mean I I think you could call it
contentedness and discontented nests
like that that's kind of what fits
naturally to me like you have if you're
too discontent like life sucks you you
end up spending 16-hour days working on
something to make the world better and
killing yourself
and that's not good but if you're so
content they are not willing to step out
and make things better things never get
better than they were
and you're stagnant
like you need the desire to make things
better but like contentedness to see all
the good that's already there it's what
is the idea I can't remember where it
came from but the idea that a virtue
lives between two vices that virtue is
sort of the absence of excess this all
brings us to the relationship between
the older brother and the younger
brother I'm glad that I'm glad that you
like that I think there are different
ways to talk about it but we're so
severely disconnected from nature that
we see all of the malevolence --is that
are here right now so that is a first
order issue that needs to be addressed
yeah and I think I think the solution to
it is pretty complex it's within us it's
within all of us and the shells people
put up around them
don't make that easy to get to and the
shells of these barriers these shields
that exist are only there because of our
initial disconnection from nature the
Mamas the spiritual leaders they from 0
to 9 they're birthed into a cave the mom
is there and other previous mamas are
there with them and they work on their
connection to earth for nine years in
darkness and then they leave the cave
and see the world for what it is Plato
would be proud
can't imagine
nine years of input of connection to
nature and nothing else that's why yeah
that's why that's why these mamas these
indigenous leaders they speak with the
deepest sense of connection to spirit
and nature that ever in my life heard
deepest everyone else that talks is like
talking from their heads everyone else
I've heard talk talks from their heads
some people especially some like
spiritual women know how to like drop
more into their hearts and their guts in
their bodies like of course but mostly
in the intellectualizing mentalizing
cognizing civilization most people are
just stuck in their heads and these
mamas these spiritual leaders they're
they're like in the interconnectedness
of everything all the time moment to
moment they're just in the
interconnectedness of everything they
really see the world differently I
highly recommend watching Aluna which is
a documentary about about what they're
trying to communicate to the world wake
up younger brother we need you to wake
up now we need you to consciously
connect to nature to remember where you
came from and what sustains you you can
still be creative but please wake up to
that conscious connection in nature
I know my room now I'm new I'm learning
my role much better now my role is to
help make sure that there's a playground
in the future and one of the ways is
through connecting the indigenous wisdom
of the planet with the science and
technology leaders of the planet across
not just San Francisco in LA Silicon
Valley in the media culture tech and
media but also to New York and finance
to London to Tel Aviv to China Middle
East yeah the world the world the world
all these massive economic centres of
tech and business and science and
finance etc they need to consciously
connect to nature in order for us to
have a playground for our children and
their children and moving forward this
is one of the most pivotal moments in a
civilizations trajectory when they
finally have a population explosion on
their planet and an exponential
technology explosion on their planet and
then then younger brother is so
disconnected from source of spirit this
is such a pivotal transitional moment
Ken younger brother win the wisdom race
can they wake up on time yeah that's the
role hopefully hopefully that's what I
can help with and yeah
so this is one of the things you know
you have these FIRST Robotics kids how
connected are they to nature as they
connect with robotics and programming
how do you see the big picture
their connection to nature and spirit at
young ages will permeate into every
other aspect of their lives everything
their interpersonal relationships with
each other with their families with
their co-workers downline with
everything with the world around them on
a moment-to-moment basis it changes
everything any sort of of malevolent
thing deception that they see in the
world of potentially things that they
can work on that are deceiving they will
see that with greater vigilance if they
connect more to nature it's another
thing there's like millions of these
kids that are in robotics programs
around the world it's so important for
them to connect to nature damn the
17-year old which is Mama's son Hannon
oh my gosh 17 year olds presence is
insane I've never seen such an awakened
soul 17 so awakened 4:17 just such
groundedness it was so beautiful so
beautiful yeah and just like so not
deceived whenever we feel like the
connection of nature spirits gone it
means that we are being deceived that is
source that is nature that's what
sustains us if we're not connected to
what sustains if something is deceiving
us
we've made a void and deception has
filled that void
it's deception but deception like the
social fabric is full of deception now I
think deception is more it's more
symptom than a cause deception is a
symptom of the first principle which is
our disconnection from nature but
calling it just like saying deception
seeps in how's this agentive it does
sense there is there are people that
they themselves are disconnected from
nature to such a degree that they make
memes that then seep into other people's
programming I I hesitate to call them
like risk responsible or malevolent for
that it is what it is and our
responsibility is to connect ourselves
consciously and then to help yeah I mean
I think like empathetically it's hard
it's hard to call someone who's been
sold a story the the world is a certain
way and you should have a certain goal
and here's things that aren't so
anything but a victim just a different
kind of victim
if we're born into connection to nature
there's no way to be deceived when we're
consciously connecting every moments in
Asia there's no way to be deceived
that's the true essence that's what
sustains us so anyway this has been yeah
has has been this has been good Nick I'm
glad that we got to to do some
conversation let's go to the Qri let's
go yeah let's go
quality researchers do has an event
that's happening on art and
consciousness looking forward to
attending that with you all right
let's do it good job Nick